hi there art lovers i know what you're
thinking john you look so cultured are
you in the world's sexiest museum well
the answer to both those things is yes
yes i am and pretty soon you can be too
because i'm happy to say that this
illustrious exhibit is about to go on
tour you may remember that last year in
an effort to help museums that were
struggling due to the pandemic we asked
museums across the united states if they
would be interested in hosting these
masterpieces that we accumulated in the
course of what was a very weird year
well for some reason many agreed so over
the next few months our collection will
be visiting exactly five museums each of
which i'm happy to say will receive a 10
000 donation from us and as a bonus
we'll also donate another 10 000
to a food bank in their area so
should you be interested in visiting our
exhibit what exactly will you see well
you will find this magnificent picture
of wendy williams eating a lamb chop
you'll also find this sad tie painted by
judith cuddler as part of a series
exploring the absence of her husband
larry and of course our pierced a
resistance and where our collection
began
stay up late
a study of rat friendship which really
has to be seen in person to be fully
appreciated just look at the brush
strokes there it's like if monet had a
furry period
so here are the tour dates we're headed
to the museum of broadcast
communications in chicago for the month
of october the american visionary art
museum in baltimore this november the
william v banks broadcast museum and
media center in detroit this december
and the cartoon arts museum in san
francisco this coming january but before
all of that the tour begins where else
but the judy garland museum in minnesota
these works will be on view there in
september as i'm just going to assume
judy would have wanted
for more information visit lwt
lwtgallery.com or john oliver has your
rat erotica.com
goodbye